what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by today and if
you've been following the news recently
about Jonathan Majors you most likely
know that he was arrested on charges of
assault and even though that him and his
lawyer claim that he is innocent and in
fact the victim in the situation he had
his first court date in early May and a
decision has not been reached yet and it
doesn't seem like anyone can determine
which way this is going to go Jonathan
majors and his lawyer have presented
text messages from the alleged victim
and have even showed photos and video
footage that are in his favor however
the woman who is the alleged victim in
this situation has not been proved to be
lying neither has Jonathan major has
been proved to be lion either so right
now it truly is a mystery as to which
way the court is going to decide however
this of course puts Marvel Studios in
Disney in a very tricky situation the
main actor that they have cast to play
the main villain of an entire MCU Saga
multiple phases is in the news right now
for being arrested and having allegedly
assaulted a woman it really is a hard
situation for everybody involved for
Jonathan Majors for the woman and for
the studio in a perfect world nobody
would be abused and nobody would be
lying unfortunately that is not the
world we live in and a lot of Jonathan
majors's team has already dropped him
like his PR team and his management team
he's also been dropped from some
commercials as well and he has also
reportedly lost some movie deals so of
course Marvel fans but the rest of the
world as well have their eyes on Disney
and Marvel Studios wondering what
they're going to do if they're going to
do anything about Jonathan Majors
playing King the Conqueror their main
villain of the Multiverse Saga and while
Disney has not released any official
statement they have done some very
official things that make it seem like
they are indeed going to recast Jonathan
majors and it really does kind of look
like that's what Disney and Marvel
Studios has decided to do here's why
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania is
coming out and of course that stars Paul
Rudd but it also Stars Jonathan Majors
as the main villain of the movie plus
not to mention the post-credits scene
there is literally thousands of Jonathan
Majors thousands of different variants
of King all played by him of course so
it really is crazy that Marvel Studios
is seemingly avoiding mentioning
Jonathan majors's name at all during any
promotional material for Quantum Mania
and Loki 2. in fact if you go to Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania right now on
Disney plus it actually doesn't even
mention the main villain Kang this is
what it says for the description
superhero partner Scott Lang and hope
Van Dyne returned to continue their
Adventures as Ant-Man and the WASP
together with Hope's parents hang Pym
and Janet Van Dyne and Scott's daughter
Cassie the family finds themselves
exploring the quantum realm interacting
with strange new creatures and embarking
on on an adventure that will push them
beyond the limits of what they thought
was possible no mention of even a
villain no Kang no the Conqueror nothing
at all now he is still credited as
playing came to conqueror of course
because they have to give him that
credit but if you take a look at a lot
of Disney sites there's no mention
anywhere of Jonathan Majors Kang and
according to a report from Alex B over
at thecosmiccircus.com Disney issued
some sort of a mandate stating that an
all-promotional material for quantumania
and Loki season 2 don't mention Jonathan
Majors this is what Alex tweeted out
today update on the major slash Marvel
situation it appears there's an order on
promotional material slash articles from
Disney regarding the arrival of
quantumania on Disney plus under no
circumstance is any article allowed to
mention Jonathan Majors or his
involvement in the film as Kang in
addition new Disney articles that are
meant to promote the film reference
majors and his role as king the
Conqueror as the following the new
threat that frightens everyone as
opposed to mentioning the actor and even
the character by name King isn't even
mentioned it simply says a new threat
but Alex continues to State Marvel may
continue to credit him for his
appearance in the film but Disney cites
and articles at this time do not mention
or bring him up in any shape or form so
no mention of Kang or Jonathan Majors
playing King simply just him being
credited as Kang in the credits and it
really does seem like this is kind of an
Overkill if this is a precaution that
Marvel is taking to kind of wait and see
how the trial goes if they are waiting
to see if he's innocent or not this is
kind of an Overkill this doesn't seem
like a precaution this seems like they
have already made up their minds this
seems like they are indeed going to
recast Kang if they are simply avoiding
saying Kang or Jonathan Majors that's a
pretty big tell and it's actually
extremely crazy that they're not even
mentioning Kang they're calling him a
threat that's how they're referring to
the character right now because right
now all of the articles are stating
Jonathan Majors King actor Jonathan
Majors Marvel actor everything that is
associated with him right now is
unfortunately bad and he is associated
directly with Kang so that's probably
why they aren't using the name Kang now
a lot of people have been asking is Kang
getting kind of wiped away is he no
longer going to be the villain of the
Multiverse Saga well fortunately we do
have some good news in this department
although Jonathan Majors May no longer
be playing Kang Kang is not going to be
removed as the villain King the
Conqueror is still going to exist in the
MCU they will simply just recast the
actor to play King the Conqueror I mean
he was already in Loki season 1 he's
going to be a huge part of Loki season
2. he's obviously the main villain of
quantumania and the post-credit for
quantumania showed us that there were
thousands of variants of Kang throughout
the Multiverse and of course we have
Avengers the King Dynasty coming up
they're not just going to get rid of the
character and Alex P even confirmed this
when somebody asked if they are removing
the character entirely Alex stated no
absolutely not Marvel is far too deep
into the Multiverse lore to back out
with King now the Multiverse Saga will
continue as for Majors everyone will
have the answer they're waiting for by
the end of Loki season 2 which is a very
interesting comment it makes me believe
that they're going to do a little bit of
rewrites with Loki season 2 and somehow
have a Kang variant come into the
picture who is not played by Jonathan
majors and from there on they could kind
of adjust the story as well stating that
the new Kang played by the new actor is
the prime king and the one that they are
seeing in Loki season 2 the one we saw
in Loki season 1 and in quantumania that
is simply a lesser variant of Kang but
the new one that comes in is the Kang
the big bad the one that is going to
appear in the Kang Dynasty the true big
bad threat they can make this new actor
that person and it'll kind of all work
out as far as continuity in the the MCU
goes now what happens if Jonathan Majors
is found innocent in this trial perhaps
they don't recast him the problem is
whatever Direction this trial goes
whether he has found innocent or whether
he is found guilty there is still going
to be opposition if he is found innocent
people are going to say well it's a
broken court system and the court system
failed the woman and the woman is
actually the victim he shouldn't have
won but if he loses then of course there
are going to be people who say Well good
I'm glad he lost because he assaulted
somebody but at that point in time if he
loses it's kind of a moot point Marvel
Studios will definitely be getting rid
of him then again we're trying to
reserve judgment until everything kind
of comes to light but unfortunately it
does look like a pretty big uphill
battle for Jonathan majors at this point
and with Disney removing all mentions of
him besides the actual credits that
seems like a pretty big tell that they
are indeed going to recast the actor or
possibly have already done so they could
have already made that move they could
have already told Jonathan Majors hey
we're sorry due to the situation you're
out and they could have already told a
new actor hey you're in his King we've
heard rumors that Marvel Studios Was
preparing for this perhaps they found an
actor in mind and they've cast them
already who knows we'll have to wait and
see what Marvel decides to do officially
when they give us that official
announcement of hey we've recast Kang or
hey John of the majors is still going to
be king in the meantime let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and leave a comment so you can
enter our giveaway for a chance to win a
PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items as well we also
have our patreon account up our website
is up as well and if you want to join
our Discord we link that in the
description down below as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof
baby